okay my pick for talk of the table is
she sings love songs too
country star mickey guyton you received
your first ever
grammy nomination best country solo
performance congratulations
oh wow that's the singer-songwriter
getting the news of her first ever
grammy nomination that was back in
november for the song black like me
she became the first black female solo
artist to be nominated for a grammy in a
country category
the vocal powerhouse in powerhouse is
the word we'll make history once again
this sunday she is co-hosting the
academy of country music awards
wow alongside fellow country star keith
urban this is a big deal
we spoke to guyton about her trials as a
trailblazer in the genre
and how she learned the big big news
about the acms
i got a phone call and it was literally
keith urban
asking me to co-host the acm awards and
you know i want to do the praise dance
and the hallelujahs and all of that
i still can't believe it country music
artist mickey guyton
is making history as the first black
woman to co-host the academy of country
music
awards for the texas native 2021 has
been a year blessings
including the birth of her baby son
grayson with husband grant savoy
we first spoke to guyton back in 2015
when her single
better than you left me was climbing the
country charts
i always think what would it be like to
drive in your car or to be wherever you
are
and you hear your song on the radio it
is do you remember that moment i do
remember that moment
my manager's driving in the car all of a
sudden i hear this familiar song
and you're just like this is what i
dreamed about
but she says soon after that
conversation she was faced with the
harsh reality of pursuing a career in
country music
as a black woman i dealt with a lot of
difficult
things being on the road and and trying
to figure out myself in country music
you know i i did get called the n word
at a show
and that was devastating to me
you're on stage mickey and someone calls
you an n-word i was doing a
after show signing and i was literally
going to hug
a kid and someone walked by me and they
said everybody's waiting for the n-word
and i just remember i looked up and i
said god bless you and i kept moving but
it hurt
but that hurts yeah mickey that hurts to
even hear that that happened to you
i think about your life how long you've
been doing this
and you never gave up i almost did i
almost did
when i had that first interview with you
i was this bright-eyed like starting out
my career like
all of these hopes and dreams and it
didn't necessarily
go the way i had planned i remember that
interview mickey
and i walked out of there and i said
it's only a matter of time yeah me too
before people see what i see there must
have been something about you that said
i believe in me
at a certain point i even didn't believe
in me
i felt like i had spent all of this time
working towards this career and i just
couldn't get off the ground
i was literally at my breaking point
that i wanted to give up and my husband
wouldn't let me do that
what did he say to you he must have said
something that resonated with you
one night i asked my husband why do you
think country music isn't working for me
and he said because you're running away
from everything that makes you different
and he said country music is three
chords and the truth right
well then why aren't you writing your
truth about being a black woman
in america singing country music and i
was like
oh my god it's right there and that's
when i wrote a song called black like me
what were you hoping would happen with
the song
well when i wrote it i remember one of
the people i wrote it with
nathan chapman turned around and said
this could be the biggest song of your
career
and it may make people very angry and
it kind of scared me because i
was like why why would my truth why
would that make
someone so angry and then after we
released it
i did get some pretty mean messages
on my social media from it how did you
handle that
you know i try to act like i'm strong
but i'm not always strong
and i'm sorry
oh mickey i'm sorry
thank you
it further proves the point
that i was trying to make with the song
you also got a lot of support for the
song
too didn't you absolutely i got so much
support from the song from all walks of
life
there are so many loving messages
from people that showed me that i was
doing the right thing
that we're showing that this is why i'm
here as weak as i've felt i still feel
strong
because i know that i'm standing up for
people that don't necessarily have that
ability it does seem to be that country
music is having a conversation with
itself as well
you know i'm talking of course about the
morgan wallin incident where he used the
n-word
does it feel different to you this time
yes and no
you hate when you see such unfortunate
videos like that for anybody and it
could have happened
to anybody in this genre it just so
happened to be morgan wallin
i think there is a lesson to be learned
from this yes he was wrong in this but
i don't necessarily think that
you cancel someone but he does need to
feel the weight of his words
i think for the longest time you know it
was able to
slip by because there weren't a lot of
people of color in the genre
but now that we're here it's forcing
people to have to think about it
are you hopeful i am extremely hopeful i
know
great things take time and i can't
expect everything to change
in an instant and sometimes you have to
meet people where they're at
and that's something that i'm learning
and i hope that i can now be a beacon
for a lot of people a beacon of light to
show that
if you stick to your true self and what
is true to you
anything can happen go mickey she is not
a woe is me girl
you know what has happened what she says
is you do the work and you keep going
but it's hard as you both know doing a
zoom
and you can't reach out and touch the
person and comfort the person because
my heart really went out when she had
when she had that little moment but you
know she's on the amc acm uh diversity
task force
she said she believes it's legit that
people really do want change and she's
glad to be part of that conversation and
best of all she has a record coming out
for the first time in
10 years wow the first one i know tony i
was so surprised that it's taken that
long
she's released music but this is her
first album yeah
that's coming out this summer i wouldn't
remember when she she was on the show
when she released the song initially
black like me yeah and we were all
very interested to see what would happen
and how it would be received
she's gotten a lot of support there's
some haterade too but she's gotten a lot
of support and she chooses
to focus on that she has a husband and a
baby and so
she feels life is good but she as we all
know we are not there yet no no we are
not but at least we're making steps in
the right direction she's a big part of
this new conversation yeah and his
country music is three
three notes and the truth there's gonna
be a lot more truth on that album i
think yeah and i like what she said
about morgan wallin that doesn't mean
that you need to be canceled i think he
too
is also doing the work and he could also
be instrumental in the change yeah and
it's great that she's just gonna
had a kid and can i say grayson has a
heck of a head of hair yeah
crazy congrats we're gonna be watching
you on sunday
it's the 56th annual acm awards sunday
night
8 7 central right here on cbs mickey as
you know is coasting with the great
keith urban going to be a good show